MORE AND MORE TESTIMONY
CORROBORATING THEN PRESIDE
TRUMP WANTED TO GO TO THE
CAPITOL AFTER HIS RALLY ON
JANUARY 6TH.
INCLUDING TESTIMONY FROM
RETIRED EASY METROPOLITAN
POLICE SERGEANT, MARK ROBINSON.
WHO IS IN TRUMP'S MOTORCADE
THAT DAY.
I WASN'T ASKED BY THE SECRET
SERVICE AGENT RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE MOTORCADE SAID THAT TRUMP
HAD A HEATED DISCUSSION WITH
HIS DETAIL ABOUT GOING TO THE
CAPITAL.
DARIUS, SERGEANT MARK ROBINSON
HE'S HERE WITH ME NOW THIS IS
FIRST TIME SPEAKING OUT ON CNN
BUT FIRST I JUST HAVE A
REMINDER FOR YOU.
THIS IS THE KEY TESTIMONY TO
THE GENERAL SIX COMMITTEE.
WATCH THIS.
>> WAS THERE ANY DESCRIPTION OF
WHAT WAS OCCURRING IN THE CAR?
WE >> KNOW, ONLY THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS UPSET.
AND THAT HE WAS ADAMANT ABOUT
GOING TO THE CAPITAL.
AND IT WAS A HEATED DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT.
SO, AT THE END OF THE SPEECH,
WE DO KNOW THAT WHILE INSIDE
THE LIMO.
THE PRESIDENT WAS STILL ADAMANT
ABOUT GOING TO THE CAPITAL.
THAT'S BEEN RELATE TO ME BY THE
TSA AGENT.
AND SO, WE DID PARTLY ELLIPSE
AND WE RESPONDED BACK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HOWEVER, THE MOTORCADE WAS
PLACED ON STANDBY.
>> SERGEANT GOOD EVENING,
THANKS FOR JOINING.
>> GOOD EVENING DON, THANK YOU.
>> TELL US MORE ABOUT HOW YOU
LEARN THE BEN PRESENT WAS
ADAMANT ABOUT GOING TO THE
CAPITAL.
>> I MEAN THE COMMUNICATION
COMES DIRECTLY FROM THE SECRET
SERVICE AGENT AND THE LEAD
OFFICER IN THE CART.
SIR CONSULAR CONCERNED ABOUT
THE MOVEMENTS OF THE PRESIDENT.
SO YOU NEED TO KNOW.
AND THE COMMUNICATIONS COMING
DIRECTLY FROM THE AGENT.
>> WHAT WAS CONVEYED TO YOU?
HOW INSISTENT.
JUST HOW INSISTENT WAS HE ABOUT
GOING?
>> WE'VE HEARD IT SEVERAL TIMES
WHILE IT WAS ON THE MOTORCADE.
I THINK DURING THE SPEECH.
SHORTLY THEREAFTER WHEN YOU
FINISH THE SPEECH.
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS GOING
INTO THE MOTORCADE AND THAT HE
WAS UPSET.
THAT HE ADAMANTLY WANTED TO GO
TO THE CAPITAL.
EVEN WE DEPARTED FROM THE
ELLIPSE HE WAS REPEATED AGAIN
THAT THE PRESIDENT.
IT WAS A HEATED ARGUMENT IN
DILEMMA.
AND HE WANTED TO DEFINITELY GO
TO THE CAPITOL.
SO WHEN WE ARRIVED AT THE WHITE
HOUSE THE MOTORCADE WAS PLACED
ON STANDBY.
>> AS WE SAY THE VERNACULAR NOW?
HOW DID THAT HIT WITH YOU GUYS
ON THAT DAY?
>> FOR ME I REALLY DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT WAS ACTUALLY HAPPENING
OUTSIDE THE ELLIPSE.
I COULD HEAR TRANSCRIPTIONS
FROM THE RADIO.
THAT LARGE CROWDS WERE GOING UP
TO THE CAPITOL.
I DID KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
SO FOR ME, TO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE ARMED SUBJECTS OUTSIDE.
TO KNOW THAT THERE ARE LARGE
CROWDS RESPOND TO.
THAT WAS ALARMING BECAUSE, ONE,
WE WEREN'T PREPARED TO DEAL
WITH THAT.
NORMALLY WHEN YOU MOVE A
PRESIDENTIAL MOTORCADE YOU HAVE
A CIGARETTE.
SO WE DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT
PERSONNEL TO DO THAT.
SO WE WEREN'T COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT.
>> WERE YOU SAYING WHAT ON
EARTH DOES HE WANT TO GO BACK
TO THE CAPITAL FOR?
WAS THAT WHEN U.S. RETHINKING.
>> I MEAN, ABSOLUTELY.
NOW KNOWING WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED THAT WOULD'VE BEEN
HORRIBLE.
HAD THE MOTORCADE RESPONDED TO
THE CAPITOL I THINK WOULD'VE
BEEN FAR WORSE.
>> THIS IS PRETTY BAD.
>> FAR WORSE, HOW SO DO YOU
MEAN?
LIVES POSSIBLY.
>> I THINK IT PROBABLY
ENCOURAGE THE LOW RIDING.
AND THEY FELT SUPPORTED.
IF THE PRESIDENTIAL MOTORCADE
CAME AND SUPPORTED THEM.
SO I THINK THE INSURRECTION
PROBABLY FELT AS IF THEY HAD TO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT.
>> WHY DID YOU SAY?
YOU SAID THAT YOU HAD BEEN IN
OVER 100 MOTORCADES WITH TRUMP
BEFORE BUT NEVER HEARD ANYTHING
LIKE THAT EVER.
WITH THOSE NOT NECESSARILY 100
MOTORCADES WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I'VE BEEN IN THE MOTORCADE
SINCE 2011.
I'VE BEEN IN SEVERAL.
AND GENERAL.
OVER 100.
>> WELL AS A QUESTION?
JOSH YOU'VE BEEN IN OVER 100
MOTORCADES AND NOTHING LIKE
THAT HAD EVER HAPPENED?
>> RIGHT.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS MOVING,
AND MY EXPERIENCE, THE
PRESIDENT'S GOING TO A
DESTINATION WE GO.
AND THERE ARE SOME MOVES THAT
JUST POP UP ALONG THE WAY.
AND IT IS ALWAYS COMMUNICATING.
IT IS ALWAYS WORKED OUT AND WE
GO.
I'VE NEVER EXPERIENCED A MOMENT
WITH THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO GO
SOMEWHERE AND THERE'S A HEATED
ARGUMENT DISPUTE AND A DEBATE
ON WHETHER NOT THE PRESIDENT
CAN GO SOMEWHERE.
AND THEN WE ACTUALLY DON'T GO
I'VE NEVER HAD THAT EXPERIENCE
BEFORE.
>> THERE'S BEEN THIS SORT OF
FALSE NARRATIVE ABOUT THAT NO
ONE WAS.
ARMED THERE IS NO FIREARMS IN
THE CROWD.
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT THERE.
YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU HEARD
OVER THE RADIO THAT PEOPLE IN
THE CROWD HAD WEAPONS.
WOULD A PRESIDENT BE REMOVED
IMMEDIATELY FROM A SITUATION
WHERE THEY'RE INDIVIDUALS WITH
WEAPONS NEARBY?
>> ABOVE THE SECRET SERVICE WAS
COMFORTABLE.
MEANING THAT THEY HAD A
SECURITY.
THEY HAD THE PROTECTION.
THAT PARTY ROUTES AND HAD
SECURITY MEASURES IN PLACE TO
KEEP THE PRESIDENT SAFE.
I CAN HEAR THE POLICE RADIO
THAT ARMED SUBJECTS ARE THERE.
I CAN HEAR THE OFFICERS
RESPONDING TO THAT.
AND THERE IS VIDEO FOOTAGE TO
SUPPORT THAT.
WHICH WAS WEIGHED ON THE
TESTIMONY AS WELL.
>> I GUESS I'M ASKING YOU TO.
LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY.
WITH THE EXPERIENCE THAT YOU
HAVE.
WHY DO YOU THINK SOMEONE WOULD
WANT TO GO INTO WOULD APPEAR TO
BE DANGER ON THAT DAY?
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE ANYONE,
ESPECIALLY IN THAT POSITION,
WANTED TO GO TO THE CAPITOL.
WE TALK ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE SOMEONE
WANTED TO GO TO THE CAPITOL
UNDER THOSE CONDITIONS.
>> SO DESPITE ALL THAT.
HIM ONE TO GO TO THE CAPITAL.
TAKE US INSIDE THE MOTORCADE
WANT TO GO BACK TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
HOW IS THAT DECISION MADE?
>> IT IS ALWAYS MADE TO THE
SECRET SERVICE.
AND THROUGH THEM.
THEIR MANAGERS THEIR
SUPERVISORS.
AND SO THEY ARE FORMED.
THE LEAD AGENT THEY FORM THE
TSA AGENT WHO WILL INFORM THE
LEAGUE CARD.
THAT WOULD BE MYSELF >> SO WE
INFORM THE MOTORCADE WHETHER OR
NOT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED ABOUT WHETHER NOT MOVE
IS GONNA BE MADE SO WE HAVE TO
PREPARE FOR THAT.
TO SECURE ROUTE TO ACTUALLY GET
THERE AND GET BACK.
AND TO KEEP AND PROTECT THE
SAFE.
>> SO THE SAMPLE YOU'RE LIKE,
WAIT, WHAT?
SEEING THAT WE MIGHT POSSIBLY
GO BACK INTO DANGER.
I'M JUST SO THANKFUL THAT IT
DID NOT.
HAPPEN AND SO, I DIDN'T REALLY
--
WHEN WE MADE THAT MOVE I
THOUGHT YOU HAD BEEN INSANE
MOVEMENT.
I THINK THE SENTIMENT WAS FELT
EVEN WITH SECRET SERVICE.
THEY WEREN'T PREPARED FOR THAT.
SO I'M JUST GLAD THAT IT DID
NOT OCCUR.
>> THE DID YOU FEEL PRESSURED?
OVER COMING FORWARD?
WERE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THE
THREATS FROM SHARING WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED?
THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
THAT DAY?
>> NO.
THE TRUTH IS THE TRUTH.
I DON'T HAVE ANY PRESSURE ABOUT
IT.
WHETHER ALL SIMPLY.
WHETHER ARE STILL WORKING.
I MEAN WE ARE CALLED UPON SOME
TIME TO GIVE TESTIMONY.
AND SO MY EXPERIENCE IS TO TELL
THE TRUTH.
TO TELL WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
SO I'M NOT ASHAMED OF THAT.
>> SERGEANT MARK ROBINSON.
I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE.
AND GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE SAFE.
AND THANK YOU FOR PROTECTING
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
AND FOR SPEAKING OUT.
AND SPEAKING THE TRUTH.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU DON.